la chronique innovation le rendez-vous
de Maxime Le Maine lors du 7 8 le mardi
Maxime vous étiez avec nous au début
d'émission on a parlé de la rentrée
scolaire on va changer de sujet
maintenant alors là on change
complètement de sujets on passe du coq à
l'âne ou du mérou au poisson rouge c'est
comme vous le voulez puisque vous les
frites je vous propose maintenant de
partir loin très loin une belle petite
musique
à la découverte des trésors enfouis de
récifs qu'Aurélien de paysages qui vous
laisse on s'en voir même temps vous êtes
sous l'eau c'est bien normal et tout ça
depuis une piscine et bien oui en
vacances et bien oui une piscine c'est
possible il suffit juste d'un peu
d'imagination et évidemment d'un
appareil développé par une société de
Morainvilliers alors cet appareil qu'on
va voir tout de suite à l'écran en
images fonctionne sur le principe de la
réalité augmentée alors pour rappel il
s'agit de diffuser via un écran dans un
espace réel des éléments avec lequel
l'utilisateur peut interagir et donc
pour parler de cette machine qui
s'appelle le Triton nous recevons ce
soir Alain Dinis bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur de la société
virtuelle dive qui a développé cet
appareil alors tout d'abord d'où vous
est venu cette idée pourquoi un appareil
pour aller sous l'eau bah écoutez en
tant que plongeur frustré d'habiter loin
de la mer et passionné des nouvelles
technologies de la formation depuis pas
mal d'années je m'étais dit que ce
serait intéressant d'utiliser tout ce
qui était virtuel et de cette
technologie liées au numérique et de
permettre aux gens via l'aspect visuel
des choses d'avoir la sensation d'être
en mer et donc quoi de plus logique que
d'apporter ces nouvelles technologies en
milieu aquatique avec l'idée de coupler
l'immersion visuelle et virtuelle par
l'image avec l'immersion aquatique donc
l'immersion réelle
le moins cher parce que vous disiez vous
étiez un plongeur frustré mais enfin ça
coûte peut-être moins cher tout de même
de prendre un billet de partir faire un
peu de plongée que de développer tout un
procédé de réalité virtuelle augmentée
en plus étanche alors j'ai pas développé
que pour moi
l'idée c'est qu'à terme c'est pas que
pour faire plaisir non l'idée à terme
c'est que des gens qui peuvent pas
plonger parce que il y a pas non
seulement le fait de partir loin le coût
du billet d'avion il de gens qui peuvent
pas malheureusement partir aux Maldives
ou au mérouges donc l'idée c'est que
n'importe qui en milieu urbain en la
campagne qui ont accès à une piscine
notamment une piscine municipale à une
base de loisirs pour elle et découvrir
les plus beaux sites de plongée en
utilisant notre appareil donc l'idée
c'est assez rigolo sur les images on a
l'impression qu'on regarde la télé sous
la piscine en fait c'est ça c'est
exactement ça avec un gros appareil
jaune voilà
c'est pas la vocation initiale du
produit mais l'idée c'est ça c'est en
fait le
l'appareil qui est en fait l'émanation
du Triton que vous aviez vu sur les
premières images là c'est la version
mobile qui s'appelle le Dolphin et avec
cet appareil là il intègre un tablette
pc donc il y a toute la possibilité la
puissance de l'informatique embarquée en
milieu aquatique avec ou on pourra
peut-être le voir après un changement
dit justement vous parlez des tablettes
PC le fameux tablette qu'on retrouve un
peu partout maintenant diverses marques
on voilà on développait à l'époque de
ces femmes marques qui sont des
appareils qui sont tout petits pourquoi
créer un appareil aussi gros aussi alors
l'appareil vous avez vu c'est un
prototype d'accord nous finalisons
l'étude sur la version future donc qui
sera la base du produit qui sera
industrialisé et qui sera optimisé au
niveau dimension donc là on a voulu
garder une certaine marge pour justement
pouvoir intégrer et tester différents
types de tablettes PC en sachant que en
fonction du fabricant il y a la taille
dimension varie à partir du moment on
aura défini quelques types de tablettes
PC qui feraient qui vont partie de la
version finale on pourra optimiser vous
avez développé votre propre tablette PC
ou alors vous êtes passé par un
constructeur qui existait non non on
utilise des tablettes PC du marché
l'idée c'est qu'à terme
quand les personnes pourront avoir
discuté sur cet appareil dans différents
magasins de sport enfin c'est ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que la personne qui a son
propre tableau de PC achètera le caisson
et pourra mettre son talon de PC je vais
pas citer de marque mais en fonction de
du tableau de PC qu'elle aura elle
lâchera qui sont correspondant elle
partira après en vacances donc dans un
premier temps on vise plutôt le marché
de l'hôtellerie de luxe des bases de
loisirs des piscines municipales ou des
clubs de sport mais à terme pourquoi pas
si on trouve un partenaire industriel
pour produire très grande échelle l'OB
c'est que n'importe qui pourra trouver
ça pas loin de chez lui et d'acheter
avant de partir en vacances
un petit peu comment ça fonctionne
concrètement comment ça marche comme on
l'utilisateur pourra s'en servir à
quelques images qui vont arriver tout de
suite l'occasion de les commenter nous
expliquer alors voilà une fois qu'on est
plongé dans l'eau avec ce dispositif
voilà alors sachant qu'il y a deux
usages il y a soit un usage en piscine
donc là c'est effectivement pour recréer
la plongée et la sensation de la
plongeur mer pour les personnes qui
peuvent pas plonger donc les personnes
handicapées ou des personnes qui ont pas
les moyens de plonger en réel et l'autre
usage c'est en mer alors là l'idée c'est
plutôt de simuler la plongée pour les
personnes qui peuvent pas aller très
profondément donc typiquement c'est que
l'utilisateur en uniquement pas le
masque tuba à l'impression de plonger à
20 mètres voire même plus et donc là
l'idée c'est non seulement du type de
diffuser des contenus sur des sites de
plongés qui ont été recréés en trois
dimensions pour que la personne puisse
déjà avoir la base cartographique du
site éventuellement rajouter en réalité
augmentée des informations sur la faune
la flore locale des indices des chasse
au trésor donc l'aspect très ludique de
la chose et l'idée à terme c'est de
permettre aux utilisateurs de de
participer de collaborer on peut
imaginer un endroit imaginons un hôtel à
l'île Maurice où il y a un récif coréen
qui n'est pas cartographié sachant qu'il
y a très peu de cartographies seulement
et qui existe c'est que tous les
utilisateurs pourront cartographier le
site petit à petit soit de plus en plus
détaillé de plus en plus seront
réutilisés ensuite dans des piscines
qui peuvent pas éponger qui sont pas
partis à l'île Maurice pour faire
plonger au Chesnay ou effectivement à
Saint-Quentin c'est un appareil qui
coûte très cher tout dépendra de du
volume de production notre idée c'est
effectivement de en version prophète
enfin plutôt luxe en visant le haut de
gamme notamment les hôtels et les
resortes ce serait d'être dans les 3000
3500 euros après si on vise une version
grand public l'idée c'est d'être à moins
de 1000 euros alors on l'a vu dans les
images il y avait pas mal de paysages de
fonds sous-marin totalement des récifs
de de coraux il y a une vertu
pédagogique écologique derrière cet
appareil en plus de l'aspect commercial
c'est vraiment notre souhait c'est de
faire passer des messages parce qu'on se
rend compte de plus en plus que le
l'état de la mer est dans un petit peu
catastrophique et très peu de gens se
rendent compte il faut vraiment être
plongeur pour pour se rendre compte des
dégâts ce qu'on souhaite c'est
sensibiliser en public les gens qui
peuvent pas spécialement aller pouvoir
au fond qui se rendent compte d'une
manière
interactive avec différents types de
messages mais tout en mettant en avant
l'aspect ludique qui est vraiment
quelque chose à faire et qu'il faut
vraiment tout faire pour protéger la mer
et les espèces sous-marines merci Alain
Denise d'être venu sur le plateau merci
Maxime nous avoir fait découvrir ce
virtual diving la société virtuelle Dave
alandini ce qui est donc le directeur
fondateur créateur de ce dispositif dont
on vient de parler merci à vous et puis
Maxime vous aimez l'innovation alors
vous allez être attentif à la prochaine
séquence dans quelques instants nous
allons parler de la révolution qui se
déroule dans les cinémas de quartiers à
Trappes par exemple les films sont
diffusés en très haute définition le
directeur de la salle le grenier à sel
elle va nous en parler pour l'instant du
cinéma justement le cinéma Les Yeux
d'Elsa c'est à Saint-Cyr-l'École va
proposer en avant-première le film Le
Petit Gruffalo c'est un film d'animation
pour les enfants qui sortira le 17
octobre avant-première prévu demain
mercredi à 16h pour récompenser les
enfants après la rentrée scolaire par
exemple ce sera 16h suivi d'un goûter en
plus films attendu puisque le livre dont
il est adapté a connu un grand succès
voici la bande-annonce pour patienter et
vous convaincre et d'y emmener vos
enfants demain mercredi
il est absolument interdit pour un
Gruffalo de s'aventurer dans le bois
très très sombre
la grande méchante à une force
incroyable donc sur une
couverture et d'une longueur incroyable
la neige tombe le vent redouble ses
efforts je n'ai pas peur dis le petit
Ruffalo